[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtone en direct
aujourd'hui avec tout ce qui se passe en
fait depuis trois semaines on s'est dit
tiens ça serait intéressant jazz et de
réconciliation alors pour en parler
trois invités dont notre chroniqueuse
isabelle picard bonjour isabelle bonjour
également alexis morano lohan qui est
quand même un régulier de l'émission
bonjour alexis et puis eddy bélanger qui
est une nouvelle chroniqueuse l'espace
autochtone d'ailleurs bonjour et dit on
va commencer par vous présenter on ne
vous connaît pas et on a envie de savoir
qui vous êtes vous venez d'où en fait je
viens de montmagny mechelen à la
communauté gay quand la plaque avaler
malécite de viger glock acuna oui
exactement
voilà et puis vous vous intéressez
évidemment aux questions autochtones
depuis toujours mais faire de la
chronique c'est nouveau c'est tout
nouveau à faire peut-être commencé à
écrire pour espace autochtone en janvier
cette année un nouveau défi et puis
l'actualité nous donne beaucoup à
couvrir cette année oui et vos
chroniques sont très appréciés
d'ailleurs je vous le dis tout de suite
là des des lecteurs du site d' espace
autochtone alors on en est au 23e jour
des manifestations
on en est au deuxième jour des
négociations
évidemment on parle de ce conflit qui
oppose les chef héréditaire web
souhaitait avec la compagnie d'oléoducs
la coastal gaz link et il ya un terme
qu'on en entend moins qu'avant en fait
le mot réconciliation oui j'ai sorti mon
dictionnaire en fait je soutiens c'est
quoi exactement l'arcade la
réconciliation c'est l'action de
rétablir l'amitié entre des personnes
brouillé l'entente entre des groupes
hostiles
on n'était pas brouiller on n'était pas
hostile on a dû comme si on vient nous
dire sur coup qu'elle génère
comme ici on vient lien discrimination
systémique
ce serait quand même assez gros dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de bruit puisqu'elle
n'y avait pas de problème
voilà tout est dit aussi demandent est
ce qu'il y avait une véritable relation
avant qu'on commence à parler de
réconciliation c'est un peu un peu
superficielle de vouloir réconcilier
quelque chose que jamais existé oui puis
c'est ça et c'est une question de qui
veut cette réconciliation à tout prix
jusqu'à présent ça avait presque l'air
d'être une réconciliation imposée voulue
par le gouvernement puis fallait nous
qu'on s'organise pour arriver là j'ai
entendu en fait cette semaine jesse
owens qui est un membre de la nation ou
10 bouhenna il est à la sib ici
commentateurs il disait la
réconciliation n'était qu'un slogan de
campagne des libéraux aussi à ce micro
quelqu'un fois on a parlé d'élections
quant à l'automne dernier c'est ainsi
quelque chose d'une belle rhétorique
c'est une belle promesse qui a quelque
part c'est montrer que c'est leur part
les coloniaux par le parti libéral parle
le gouvernement canadien comme quelque
chose pour se sortir de passes et qui
pour propos dire qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'était on s'excuse et on a fait
les pensionnaires d'un nul colonialisme
et c'est du passé la situation n'existe
plus si on est dans une optique comme
sur les situations n'existerait plus
pourquoi on aurait besoin aujourd'hui
d'être justement régler les problèmes
quels seraient les problèmes aujourd'hui
tant ccc nous enfermer à quelqu'un par
ben dans cette logique l'heure où un le
colonialiste et que les quelque chose du
passé si on accepte que la
réconciliation doit se faire sans parler
des colonisations m 1 on en a parlé
peut-être un peu trop tôt justement pour
moi la réconciliation c'est une finalité
et pour s'y rendre justement il faut
repenser le système je les dis souvent
ici je les dis souvent ailleurs il faut
en sortir peut-être de la boîte de la
loi sur les indiens aux autres que la
repenser repenser nos relations
également avec le gouvernement et elle
m'est apparu disons comme un slogan jeu
tout à fait d'accord elle est un peu
superficielle elle a été amenée par le
gouvernement trudeau en voulant se
donner peut-être un peu bonne conscience
en velin voire peut-être une une belle
vision de l'apport de l'international
antilles il y avait tout ça aussi dans
cette image là qui a été donnée à cette
réconciliation à cette réconciliation là
mais de l'intérieur dans les communautés
notamment il même pour les autochtones
qui vivent en ville
elle n'a jamais eu lieu je voulais une
croire il ya quatre ans mais elle n'a
pas eu lieu comme j'aurais voulu que ça
se passe et je pense que c'est ce qu'on
est en train de vivre maintenant c'est
un peu le résultat de ce constat là de
la part de plusieurs autochtones au pays
c'est même moi qui éteins l'église
l'ancien péquiste souverainiste qui a
pas tendance à avoir confiance
gouvernement fédéral puisqu'elle surtout
pas qu'on a tendance à avoir confiance
en intrus d'eau j'y croyais j'avais
espoir je me tire pas ce que c'est
normal on veut personne est une victime
on veut tous pouvoir se vivent au delà
de notre mouvement vivre au delà de 2
qu'est-ce qu'on use essential hisser
notre identité de victime de deux
personnes qui ont eu qu'a eu à subir la
colonisation qui ont été lus à subir des
pensionnats la dépossession nos
territoires de nos langues avec personne
n'a envie de rester dans statut de
victime là on est tous à la vie de
croire à quelque chose comme ça quand on
joue à l'oeuvre sur ce point
alors évidemment il l'a dit beaucoup
avant d'entamer son premier mandat
lorsque les élections de l'automne
dernier sont arrivés le mot
réconciliation commençait déjà être un
peu moins crier mais on l'entend encore
beaucoup beaucoup chez les commentateurs
on le voit au téléjournal d'un différend
l'indien aussi selon les spécialistes du
commentaire de la politique fédérale
ça revient encore beaucoup oui mais là
la réconciliation quelque chose comme un
qui est en marche on a vu alex
castonguay a affirmé ça dans sa
chronique que les chefs savait que la
réconciliation est en marche c'est un
processus long tout ça on voit beaucoup
de commentateurs qui connaissent pas
bien sujet autochtone qui sont appelés à
commenter sur ce parce que c'est quand
même un élément de politique générale le
répéter le répéter le répéter le répéter
puis encore utiliser ça comme un smoker
plutôt que comprendre justement c'est
quoi qui vient avec cette réconciliation
est ce qu'elle inquiétudes aussi de dire
que c'est à cause d'eux les autres ndiso
payton que la réconciliation ne pourra
plus ou ne pourra pas avoir lieu
l'impression que ça pourrait être
utilisé en fait comme comme raison puis
moi ce que je déploie beaucoup c'est
d'entendre un discours qui est vraiment
pas la risée les canadiens en ont assez
les québécois ont été très patients ok
donc à certains une masse on est
qualifié parfois de canadiens
autochtones aux québécois autochtone et
se nourrit électrique existe pour vrai
pour plusieurs autochtones qui ont un
parent québécois donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de nous c'est quoi la place qui a
pour les autochtones à cette
réconciliation le nasr pays là on parle
de réconciliation mais est ce qu'on est
vraiment prêt à aller aborder les enjeux
c'est quoi la place qui va nous rester à
la fin je pense en fait que dans un
premier mandat juste être dos réalisée
qu'est ce que c'était vraiment à travers
les années la réconciliation la vraie
chose et c'était beaucoup plus difficile
qu'un simple slogan et c'est peut-être
pour cela que deux sa part moi
personnellement effectivement je les
moyens entendu dans la campagne de cet
automne oui oui et la réconciliation
évidemment elle elle concerne aussi les
les premiers ministres des provinces
dans la bouche de françois legault est
ce que la réconciliation est un terme
crédible ben on a encore envie d'y
croire quand il s'est excusé suite au
rappel vieille avait l'air sincère
qu'est-ce qui disait à ce moment là mais
après ça ces actions nous nous laisse
peu d'espoir c'est y est absurde avec la
rencontre des chefs le il vient parler
d' ak-47
il demande à ce qu'ils ont des faces les
ibériques à drap images comprend que
rien de son côté d'un point de vue
politique il faut qu'il donne quelque
chose à sa base qui donne quelque chose
à ceux qui ont ou qui ont voté pour lui
à ceux qui ont voté pour lui mais il
reste qu en faisant assaut il vient
encore jeter d'huile sur le feu
c'est pour pourvoir pour défaire des
erreurs qui fait lui-même soit dire que
oui il faut régler ça rapidement oui la
police voir embarquer le sa
justification pour dire finalement on
bougera pas trop vite c'est les méchants
indiens sont violents sont dangereux il
faut déconstruire un peu qu'est ce qui
se dit
quand on utilise des termes comme ça
c'est autant le vieux que j'ai tant
qu'on est d'aider des indiens violents
étaient là pour lui la façon de
justifier qu'il n'y avait pas eu
d'actions alors ça aurait été tellement
un beau prétexte de dire on n'intervient
pas via la mer parce qu'on sait
maintenant que c'est pas la bonne chose
à faire parce qu'on sait que ça va pas
régler le problème en profondeur plutôt
que ça encore sortir le spectre de les
méchants puis on on est tellement en
danger là mais je trouve que raté une
très belle occase
on a de faire preuve qu'il ya quelque
chose qui a été appris des leçons de la
crise d'oka de ces fameuses démarche là
qui ont lieu depuis cinq ans va à la
réconciliation mais s'est passé parce
qu'on a vu si on devait remplacer le
terme réconciliation par quoi on le
ferait par quel bout fort d'un esprit
désolé c'est clairement la
décolonisation de la déconstruction t'es
pas d'accord par canadien chez les
autochtones des colonies on ya même des
t-shirts qui sont faits à l'éffigie
depuis quelques années qu'on nous c'est
vraiment ça on peut pas juste serrer la
main
le gouvernement s'excuser donner des
compensations sans changer le noeud du
problème sans s'embarrasser les carpes y
faire un nouveau jeu ça sera possible ça
fonctionne repos il faut des colonisés
et ça ça prend du courage pour
décoloniser il faut pas l'oublier parce
que les conséquences de la
décolonisation sont beaucoup plus large
réconciliation la réconciliation dans le
fond c'est comment on pourrait légitimer
cette étude c'est être coloniale d'un
comment on peut légitimer les actions du
gouvernement
des structures coloniales qui sont
toujours en place c'est un peu ce qu'il
ya derrière ce tandis que cinq ans parle
de décolonisation ce qu'il faut de
défaire ses structures le biais retrait
des nouvelles on parle de changement
concessionnels le puits on l'a vu
aujourd'hui à vingt textes à
s'intéresser de raphaël picard qui
parlait de tout dans la presse jusqu'à
ma commun la loi constitutionnelle selon
son texte est aujourd'hui faite dans le
fond pour tuer notre site aborigènes
puis à faire en sorte que l'on n'ait pas
droit progresse de dans cet état
colonial le commun justement pour en
arriver à quelque chose d'autre faudrait
refaire on le fait avec charlton y avait
des propositions que les autochtones
puissent devenir un ordre de
gouvernement
ben
et c'est un peu ce que je défends que ça
passe par la souveraineté du québec
éventuellement pour refaire c'est un
nouvel obs fonctionnel en écumant les
premières nations à paul st pierre
plamondon un peu proposé ça dernièrement
c'était quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant ça reste à voir comment ça
peut se faire après ou bien du parti
québécois qui parle je sais pas comme un
exposé à vivre dans un canada où on
referait le canada puis on pourrait
avoir une classe sérieuse
je pense qu'il faudrait passer la
monarchie faudrait s'en sortir des
symboles monarchiques parce qu'en ce
moment si on regarde le droit comme un i
fonctionne ce que c'est tout le temps
l'autorité de la couronne de la reine
qui est délégué pic est géré par les
haut-parleurs par les délais légaux des
différents gouvernements
donc si on suit cette logique là les
décisions un judicial les décisions du
gouvernement finalement sont des
délégations de l'autorité et on délègue
une certaine partie de l'autorité au
gouvernement fédéral une autre partie de
l'autorité aux eaux couronne provinciale
dans des arrêts importants comme sport
haut de gamme
canter ainsi de suite la cour suprême a
dit que le site ancestrale aborigènes
était pressé d'un de la souveraineté la
couronne britannique et qu'il fallait
gérer ce partage de souveraineté lomé au
bout de la langue qu'est ce qu'elle est
les délais des décisions de la cour
suprême
au fond c'est qui qui a fait 1 toujours
les intérêts de la souveraineté
autochtone à la souveraineté canadienne
en 10 heures que c'est pour le meilleur
intérêt que c'est pour l'intérêt de la
couronne et des choses comme ça donc on
peut tout le temps porter atteinte aux
tisserands c'est celle au droit
autochtone de cette façon là si ça vient
rejoignent l'intérêt c'est bon pour
l'intérêt de la majorité
donc si on veut star c'est justement de
cette logique-là d'autorité déléguée à
une autorité partager comme on le
prétend de dans les jugements de la cour
suprême et finalement de facto c'est pas
ça qui arrive il faudra aussi symbole de
l'art en pid eng le faire justement des
discussions constitutionnelles pour
qu'on puisse vraiment parler de
souveraineté partagée entre la couronne
sur balmont prend le fédéral se serait
plus la couronne entre le fait de mal en
pis province et les nations autochtones
et dit je vous ai pas posé la question à
vous réconciliation on enlève le terme
on le remplace par quoi est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le mot décolonisation
mais je suis d'accord avec des
colonisations jeu j'aime bien ça par
contre indiqué ce que c'est pas donc on
doit se décoloniser pour faire quoi pour
est arrivé en relation et établir une
relation serait seul objectif puis on
voit bien la complexité de sa j'aime
décoloniser parce qu'on en dise en soit
on dit qu'on remet aux différentes
nations
la possibilité de se construire une
identité de se construire des structures
qui vont vraiment leur convenait alors
que lorsqu'on a cédé structures
coloniales qui ont été imposées aux
autochtones comme un bloc monolithique
ce qui est une réalité qui quitte à peu
près irréel autochtone avec toutes les
différences qui a entre les différentes
communautés différentes nations si on
avait chacun à choisir des modèles de
gouvernance de partage des
responsabilités
on arriverait pour tous avec la même
formule donc
je pense que des colonisations c'est ça
qu'on a besoin en ce moment à 6 pour
aller éventuellement voir une nouvelle
relation beaucoup plus d'égal à égal
alors si on présente ce terme là au
gouvernement fédéral à justin trudeau
suis pas sûr qu'il va accepter d'emblée
n'est ce pas donc on va essayer de
trouver la transition comment on peut en
arriver ça va être quoi la transition
pour se rendre jusqu'à ce qu'un jour le
gouvernement fédéral accepte de penser à
la décolonisation
mais hier j'avais eu une discussion avec
un ancien chef de parti politique et je
parlais justement de décolonisation et
il me ramenait donc aux conflits actuels
il me ramenait au chef héréditaire en
disant que bon c'était pas démocratique
que ça suivait pas donc le droit
canadien que c'est bon et donc je vois
bien que même au niveau des politiciens
qui nage donc dans la politique et dans
et c'est pas un terme qui va être
accepté facilement pourquoi parce qu'ils
ne connaissent pas ce que c'est que ces
systèmes de gouvernance des systèmes
politiques ou autres culturel
précoloniale donc pour moi l'éducation
m'apparaît le pont entre la
réconciliation et la décolonisation
parce que quand on explique notamment au
niveau des chef héréditaire d'où ça
vient qu'est ce que c'est que là on voit
les lumières s'allument et on voit les
jeunes à oui ok je n'avais pas vu comme
ça moi je pensais que c'était des
illégaux donc on a beaucoup de préjugés
qu'il faut défaire je pense que
l'éducation c'est un pont un des ponts
en tout cas qu'il va falloir emprunter
pour y arriver
et puis on reste on est en 2020 c'est si
on laissait vraiment le choix aux
nations comme une autre et de se décider
des structures jeu pas certaine que tout
le monde n'irait avoir un modèle de chef
héréditaire
il y en a peut-être qui resterait très
proche de ce qu'on actuellement qui
était imposé par la loi sur les indiens
parce que je sais quoi ça lui a permis
de se développer ça ça les rend plus
confortable pour l'instant il faut bien
qu'ils aient survécu
oui parce que
je regarde ma nation beaucoup de nos
structures d'atlanta ont été détruites
donc on a réussi quand même à faire
survivre certains éléments au travers de
ses conseils le quand même de ces
structures le colonial qui on peut le
voir les nice guerre ont décidé
justement pas retraités de se créer une
constitution où les gens pouvaient voter
où on remplacer ses systèmes
traditionnels de gouvernance par des
systèmes plus démocratique mais qui sont
qui découle d'une constitution ni ce qu
il yad autres communautés aussi d'autres
nations qui sont en train de se
développer des idées des constitutions
comme seul shekel processus est en cours
en ce moment chez les images de voyage
est intéressant parce que j'avais parlé
de chefs traditionnels et puis en fait
les gens étaient aussi beaucoup mais les
moi même d'ailleurs je l'étais entre
chef héréditaire et chefs traditionnels
parce qu'au québec on ne parle pas de
chef héréditaire il n'y a pas de chef
héréditaire
ce sont des chefs traditionnels les
doigts et les deux territoires
alors c'est quoi la différence ben en
fait les deux
que ce soit les chefs héréditaire ou des
chefs traditionnels se sont ils prennent
leur source en fait dans un système de
gouvernance qui est pré colonial donc
c'est assez clair au niveau des chef
héréditaire chez les ouates souhaité m
dans le cas qui nous intéresse ici ce
sont des chefs qui sont donc c'est un
nom qui est passé d'un homme à un autre
pas nécessairement du père au fils là
mais à ses yeux c'était à l'intérieur
même classée comme la monarchie en
angleterre par exemple donc donc mais
c'est à l'intérieur du même club donc
cette personne là le chef monsieur x
faut choisir un monsieur y pour le
remplacer et il ya tout un système
monsieur y donc la personne pressentie
pour devenir le chef héréditaire vont
devoir se retirer en forêt ça c'est
encore pendant une trentaine de jours
réfléchir oui réfléchi puis au futur de
sa nation de 2 son clan de sa communauté
donc tout un système le traditionnel qui
s'inscrit à l'intérieur de ça maintenant
ça c'est pour les huit souhaitait au
québec on voit beaucoup encore chez les
mots rock c'est quand même assez actif
dont on parle surtout de mer de clans
donc on a là aussi des clans le clan de
l'ours par exemple le clan du loup
vrai et caetera et on a à l'intérieur de
ces clans la dmr deux clans qui vont
choisir donc des chefs qui eux vont
représenter le clan qui ne sont pas donc
des chefs de conseils de bande mais qui
vont quand même être consultés gg vous
savez dans ma vie personnelle
l'intérieur j'étais un marié avec le
chef de kanesatake et le grand chef de
kanesatake et ayant quand même des
consultations entre les deux dont la
partie plus traditionnel et la maryse
conseil de bande leur impose chez les ch
et les malécites chez les abénakis
est-ce qu'il ya encore des chefs
traditionnels il ya encore un vestige de
cette structure la baie qui se rattache
avec la confédération web anaky donc
c'est géré de façon beaucoup plus large
dans les nations de la confédération
habana qui puis le pouvoir est encore
aux femmes
donc c'est les grands-mères qui vont
vraiment décidés les grandes actions
importantes puis on l'a vu beaucoup au
nouveau brunswick l'a dernièrement dans
la dernière année camp de l'amison qui
parle c'est sûr aucune terre de réserve
qui passait sur le territoire
traditionnel de wallace togo c'est les
grands mères qui ont vraiment levé les
drapeaux qui ont mobilisé les gens puis
là on a vu les rôles de chefs
traditionnels tu es surtout des porte
parole de ce que les grands m'en voulais
vraiment faire entendre cette voix
l'appui d'un des à ce que la
mobilisation se mettant en place donc et
encore des vestiges de ça mais c'est pas
tant au niveau des banques c'est
vraiment au niveau plus large la nation
puis même de la confédération des
nations alors si on décoloniser la
société s comment ça changerait qu'est
ce que ça changerait d'entre autres dans
votre nation 60 bonnes questions je
pense qu on est déjà un prêt une fois ce
processus là les communautés se pose
déjà la question comment on peut
intégrer le traditionnel dans nos
structures de gouvernance actuelle donc
ça peut être par l'afld par le conseil
des sages par exemple qui existe dans
notre communauté
sauf toute façon on arrive presque à un
modèle hybride
donc oui on a la structure
d'administration qui les élus mais
il ya un appel il ya un appel au conseil
des sages pour les questions importantes
doivent vraiment un dialogue en continu
ça je pense que c'est c'est de cette
façon là que ça se ferait on n'a pas
nécessairement faire un choix
on y va du traditionnel au niveau salon
la loi sur les indiens on n'est
peut-être pas obligé de tout drastiques
chez les abénakis et alexis ouais
premièrement j'espère vrai que c'est
plus nous nous donner des territoires
son voeu un parent ou les deux de
décolonisation faut parler de notre lien
avec le territoire nous autres les
abénakis de communauté abénaquise du
québec
notre territoire est rendue privatisé à
95%
ce qui fait que beaucoup nos chasseurs
beaucoup de nos membres doivent demander
à 10 des cultivateurs la permission
d'aller d'aller chasser sur leurs terres
pour pouvoir pratiquer leurs activités
traditionnelles
donc moi c'est ça quand je pense à la
décolonisation c'est la décolonisation
nous exprimons structure mais il faut
aussi parler de la réparation de la
réparation que la restitution aussi je
dis pas qu'on va reprendre tout le
territoire il ya bien meilleure vie de
manière ça serait pas viable ce serait
pas vraiment passé mais l'idée d'avoir
comme des portions territoire où on
pourra les pratiques et puis pouvoir
enseigner le nos traditions et ainsi de
suite je pense que ça pourrait être une
des partie de la réponse dans la partie
restitution est reprise en contrôle de
nos territoires français ça va vouloir
dire ou si un droit puis un consentement
pas juste une question d'être consultés
quand il s'agit de développement de
projets en ce moment l'obligation qu'ont
sionnel obligations que le
la course vraiment d'année au
gouvernement c'est de consulter les
premières nations
si on arrive avec lui si la déclaration
universelle des droits des peuples
autochtones ya beaucoup d'éléments la
dame on devrait parler de consentement
libre et éclairé aussi isabelle je vous
pose la même question celle et wendat on
agirait en conseil traditionnel est ce
qu il en existe un conseil au 100 m
il ya quand même un système un peu
parallèle c'est pas nécessairement des
chefs de nommer par il ya quand même des
maires de clan maintenant c'est plus au
niveau spirituel donc on a commencé par
là je pense à luanda qui note des
colonisations parce que on était on va
pas se le cacher extrêmement colonisés
et dans les années 90 post crise de
khost a eu vraiment il ya eu une espèce
de pluie de hockey ont d'authenticité
on voulait avoir quelque chose de réel
on était peut-être talent et j'ai grandi
avec des tipis avec des totems alors que
c'est pas du tout dans ma culture donc
eu un retour aux sources qui est passé
par donc les cérémonies traditionnelles
à la maison longue ce qu'on veut ce que
je voyais pas quand j'étais tout petit
c'est arrivé quand j'avais peut-être 12
13 ans dans la communauté
évidemment le rôle de set dont cette
partie de la population la haye et et
les différentes de celles du conseil de
bande chez nous c'est à dire que ce sont
les gardiens de la langue de la culture
de la spiritualité
alors que le conseil de bande va pas
vraiment joué dans ces eaux là bien sûr
au niveau de la culture ils vont quand
même faire à ce niveau là mais disons
que tous étaient venus du mouvement
traditionaliste à wendake et de là à
décoloniser le système de gouvernance
actuelle je pense qu'on est pas rendu là
il ya eu quand même au début des années
2000 un peu comme ce que j'entendais de
la part des malécites il ya eu quand
même aussi rebrassage du système de
gouvernance tel qu'il était avant
c'est à dire que nous aussi maintenant
on a un conseil des sages on a divisé
disons chaque famille chaque grande
famille peut avoir un chef un peu issus
des clans mais l'ordre quand une autre
histoire des clans traditionnels mais je
pense qu'ici on voulait vraiment
décoloniser faudrait repenser tout ça
encore une fois parce qu'on a fait des
efforts des bonds importants
puis nous aussi on se décoloniser petit
à petit s'est pas fait du jour au
lendemain dans nos communautés ça veut
pas dire que tout le monde va adhérer
les gens sont habitués insiste un
certain système
ils doivent aussi être éduqués et je
pense que quand ils le sont
tranquillement l'on y voit les
changements qui voit ce que ça pourrait
apporter gens qui ont ce décolonisons se
décoloniser en tant que personne n'ose
curie on a beaucoup beaucoup intériorisé
la colonisation intériorisé
l'infériorisation intériorisé beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments de ce qui faut s'en
sortir soit remplissent aussi c'est un
travail qui peut facilement vous êtes
d'accord est dit là se décoloniser soi
même ça oui ça me parle puisse aider
quelle belle occasion la voir des
discussions aussi des discussions
familiales là dessus des d'échanger des
visions puis c'est probablement un des
grands avantages du moment de crise
comme ça c'est que ça ça force à saül
les portes puis ça nous permet d'aborder
des sujets qu'autrement on n'aura
peut-être pas eu le courage d'aborder
des lots est un moment historique et
entre les anciens entre les aînés et les
plus jeunes à travers les diverses
générations à ce qu'on a
est ce qu'on a le même schèmes de pensée
là est-ce qu'on jeu je parle beaucoup
avec mon nom verbal
oui c'est moi ça me parle beaucoup ça
parce que si je regarde deux générations
en arrière génération de mes grands
parents un subissait vraiment qu'est ce
que c'était d'être autochtone subissait
tout ce qui venait avec la loi sur les
indiens subissent l exclusion subi cela
avait peur avait honte aujourd'hui je
regarde la génération et même aux plus
jeunes que ceux-là je regarde les plus
jeunes à ma communauté et puis je trouve
ça fait du bien je vois qu'il ya
vraiment une fierté qui était même pas
là il ya peut-être vingt ans ça j'ai
l'impression que c'est sept supporters
c'est vraiment par tant d'espoirs parce
qu'ils se réapproprient leur identité
ils veulent savoir
il veut savoir qui sont ils veulent
connaître l'histoire puis ça mais ça
c'est une partie essentielle pour
contribuer à la communauté comme un ton
histoire commenté tradition à être
vraiment un crime surtout sur son
identité c'est primordial
est ce que cette fierté là est ébranlé
par ce qui se passe en ce moment à
travers le pays avec évidemment cette
opposition entre les chefs héréditaire
qu'aux gazzin mais également les
manifestations à travers le pays moi je
pense pas je pense que les renforcer
au contraire je pense que ça va forcer
justement des gens des premières nations
qui connaissent peut-être moins tout ce
qui se passe les enjeux les défis parce
qu'il y en aura pas parce qu'on est
autochtone qu'on connaît tous il faut le
rappeler est donc ça les force à se
poser des questions retourne en arrière
à apprendre un peu comme la crise d'oka
a fait dans les années 90 je pense que
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
mehal contrairement à la crise d'oka en
fait différemment c'est qu'à la crise
d'oka est ce que les différentes nations
les les gens dans les différentes
nations ont eu tendance à se replier sur
eux mêmes puis au contraire a essayé de
cacher ça et aujourd'hui on est fier
quand même de dire oui je suis il y
avait logiquement les races et cela on
peut pas nier
un pilleur beaucoup beaucoup
d'intimidation qui peuvent se passer sur
les médias sociaux moi je vois des amis
qui habitent dans différentes régions
qui se font encore herman traité de
k-ways d'indiens salle de sauvages des
choses comme ça donc oui vas avoir
sûrement des conséquences mais justement
clients on aviv serait confronté à ça ça
nous oblige à nous positionner un même
si on n'est pas positionné à quelques
portes mais aussi de mémoire par rapport
à la crise d'oka il me semble que c'est
moins polarisé quand même puis on entend
beaucoup plus à mon souvenir d'eux
aujourd'hui on attend beaucoup plus de
québécois qui vont défendre qui vont
défendre des autochtones qui ont des
commentaires racistes qui peuvent
recevoir me semble que c'etait pas si
présent que j'ai je pense qu'on évoluent
c'est bon si oui mais le fait aussi que
les autochtones soient présents dans les
médias pour expliquer je pense que cela
fait vraiment toute la différence par
rapport à 1990 ce matin où il hier soir
j'entendais qui eût sondage angus reid
qui demandait aux gens donc aux
canadiens et vous en accord avec le bon
ce qui se passe les blocus dont les
revendications des autochtones et 44% de
la population nous appuyer je veux dire
en 1990 là je vais pas je vais pas
présupposer mais je pense que ça aurait
été peut-être kw à 7 8%
donc vraiment une compréhension qui fait
en sorte 40 comme moi je suis quand même
fier qu'aujourd'hui on ait le courage de
dire non on ne veut pas ça et on veut
tenir notre bout maintenant dans le
comment on pourrait alors parler mais
juste juste de dire les choses
je pense que c'est important on en est à
la deuxième journée de négociation sur
le site de la nation des watts ou étonne
en colombie britannique
on ne sait pas comment les choses vont
évoluer
à quoi vous attendez vous au cours des
prochains jours des prochaines semaines
aussi ça peut avoir évidemment un
beaucoup de répercussions
mais êtes-vous positif devant la
situation est ce que vous pensez que ça
va se régler pour le mieux mais déjà
qu'il y ait discussion je pense qu'il
était temps
je pense qu'il faut commencer par ça
évident
mais maintenant on entend plein de
choses on entend bon les demandes des
chefs héréditaires il y en avait deux
principales le retrait de la grc du
territoire et un moratoire au niveau des
travaux ce que j'en sais c'est que la
grc est encore dans le coin et essence
sont encore le respecte ouais c'est ça
c'est pas tout à fait donc ce qu'on lit
puisqu'on ce qu'on entend des réseaux
sociaux parce qu'on a quand même les
autochtones on est quand même en lien
assez facilement au niveau des réseaux
sociaux et ça nous amène à nous livrer
nouvelle donc c'est pas tout à fait s
est ce que justement le fait qu'on n'est
pas tout à fait accordées aux ferries
dit à wenzhou est est ce qu'il
souhaitait est-ce que ça va pas retarder
les choses ou faire qu'on va être
méfiant et qu'on engage repose une vraie
conversation
c'est un début je suis confiante qu'on
trouve une solution mais la solution se
trouvera pas du jour au lendemain parce
que à travers ce conflit là selon moi ce
sont des générations et des générations
de difficultés de problèmes de besoin de
cocon adresse finalement on en revient
toujours à ça les problèmes de fond
j'entendais un commentaire du ministre
garneau de transport fédéral des ifs
j'espère que ça va être positif mais il
faut démanteler les barricades
est ce que c'est ça l'objectif
démanteler les barricades je pense pour
si c'est avec cet esprit là qui rentrent
en négociation
ça risque de pas fonctionné en deux
jours c'est pas beaucoup non plus deux
jours pour arriver à régler ce conflit
là qui a enflé enflé parce que pour les
watts ou et n 7 fait dix ans que ça dure
donc moi je pense une question de
regretter beaucoup cette semaine on a
entendu négocier de bonne foi et négocié
de bonne foi c'est vraiment discuter des
objectifs communs aux boules puis
l'objectif commun c'est plus que
démanteler les barricades
est-ce que vous pensez que les personnes
qui sont sur place pour négocier mais
également à ottawa les gens sont prêts à
écouter et à prendre le temps qu'il
faudra pour comprendre et travailler
avec les voitures et tous sont prêts
dans quel but je rejoins tout à fait ce
que tu dis est ce que le but c'est
seulement justement de démonter les
barricades et et de faire rouler
l'économie
et ça malheureusement ils vont avoir une
surprise parce qu'on va être encore le
convoi se rend compte 220 être encore
plus peut-être faire donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut viser il faut vraiment aller
plus loin ben faudrait un des
conférences concessionnaires au bout de
la ligne
non le fruit pas mûr de free première le
film n'est pas un gouvernent avec vous
qui ont trop bas de caisse qu'elle
québec pour la demande et qui veut
s'engager là dedans mais ça va être la
finalité va falloir s'en aller un jour
parce que si on veut discuter du titre
ancestrale faut discuter des compétences
qui viennent avec
puis quand on parle de compétence on
arrive nécessairement la constitution
donc on va toujours tourner en rond si
en règle
on fait juste donné d'été des solutions
superficielles pour aller au fond du
problème ils font de problèmes et le
sait pas parce qu'on n'a pas tenté de
l'agresser
il faut rappeler les commissaires dont
on parlait tout à l'heure je dis rien eu
combien de rapports depuis 1995 la
commission royale limite jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je suis en réalité toutes
les solutions qu'elle me donne à la
commission royale sur les peuples
autochtones erasmus dussault on ne
serait pas là aujourd'hui on serait
peut-être justement au delà de cette
confrontation l'opinion pour
éventuellement penser à vivre dans la
réconciliation
il ya eu une question que l'on s'est
souvent posé en entrevue c'est bon c'est
quoi la solution c ils nous posent à
nous comme autochtone c'est quoi la
solution au regard de la bibliothèque
elle est dans la ville vient pays
rapporte finalement dû mettre sur la
table oui tout à fait oui l'idée a
quasiment acquis et à ce niveau là puis
si les grands mamans n'ont pas pris ces
occasions là pour apprendre nous on le
fait nous on a appris de ses crises
locke de ces commissions là donc je
pense que les solutions n est pas une et
qui n'est pas une il y en a plusieurs
puits y ont été abordés ont été évalués
par des gens vraiment crédit donc
s'agisse s'agit de mettre en application
de mettre les moyens là
rebondir ce que tu dis on a appris je
pense que c'est un des éléments quand
même de la crise actuelle qui qui qui
est positive qui c'est de voir comment
justement la force de la réaction
pourquoi un des facteurs pourquoi est ce
si grande je pense est en cause que nous
nos jeunes sont aujourd'hui pas mal plus
éduqués ils sont pas mal plus conscience
ils se comprennent le système colonial
pouvons pas juste le subir veulent
défaire donc cette force là justement
qui épie l'étendue la contestation ses
courses tous côtés je pense que ça
démontre justement qu'on a une
population qui comprend qu est ce qui se
passe puis qui veut que ça change
est-ce qu'on est confronté à deux
visions nous nous les autochtones là on
voit de plus en plus dans nos
communautés dans nos nations où on veut
aller
est ce que est ce que c'est ça qui
manque au niveau du gouvernement ne
savent pas quelle place il va nous
donner dans leur pays dans l'eure dans
leur façon de vivre
est ce que c'est ça donc là nous on a
une force dont on a une avance et on
s'envoie par là ça vous parle
on savait tous droite on va pas on va
plier et vous êtes de plus en plus ça le
dire haut et fort aussi oui je me
souviens il ya quelques années j'avais
entendu ghislain picard qui est là
depuis longtemps comme un chef de
l'assemblée des premières nations québec
labrador et qui disait vous allez voir
dans quelques années les jeunes vont
être moins pas celles que nous et je
pense que c'est un peu ce qui est en
train de se passer maintenant il ya
aussi comme disait alexis bien sûr une
meilleure connaissance du système de
l'histoire et ses meilleurs cette
impatience là de dire écoutez on a
répondu à vos questions en effet vos
commissions on a été patients on a
discuté on hamm est là ces cétacés
il ya un peu de ça je trouve dans ce qui
est en train de se passer aujourd'hui
cette discussion sur la réconciliation
nous a permis de ratisser large merci
merci d'avoir été là pour pour en
discuter avec nous la semaine prochaine
on approche de la journée internationale
des femmes
et là tout à l'heure isabelle vous
parliez des maires de clan alors les
maires de clan on ne les entend pas
beaucoup elles agissent en silence
est ce que c'est le cas des femmes aussi
qui veulent avoir occupé des postes de
pouvoir des femmes autochtones occupé
des postes de pouvoir autant dans leur
société que dans la société en général
et donc ce sera la discussion de la
semaine prochaine avec marie-eve bord de
l'eau est également avec manon jeannotte
qui est une ancienne chef de communauté
de la nation micmac agace peg
à l'heure où les deux seront là moi je
ne serais pas là par contre c'est
marie-france à bastad au qui va me
remplacer donc journalistes il s'est
même à radio canada mais entre temps
merci beaucoup à tous les trois comment
on dit merci
exactement et je vais rappeler
évidemment qui vous êtes et dit je vais
le dire le nom de votre communauté n'est
ce pas je vais mettre mes lunettes ou à
la stoïque père était là le cul se
prononce ou pas assez bien parce que
voyez dans les fiches de radio canada on
a enlevé le qi indienne ont le cul ne se
prononcent pas excellent on va vous
faire enregistrer la capsule s'agit
exactement comment le dire donc de
cacouna
vous êtes une malécites de cacouna une
aulas toudic
ouf j'ai réussi merci beaucoup alexis
haulot hâte de la nation abénakis bien
sûr et puis isabelle picard de la nation
wendat merci à vous trois et bonne
semaine
merci merci également à vous d'avoir été
là encore une fois cette semaine donc la
semaine prochaine nous allons parler des
femmes des femmes autochtones et de ce
fameux plafond de verre a brisé à tous
merci au revoir
[Musique]